never have I ever had sex in space well
[Music]
hi my name is Clayton Anderson and I'm a
retired United States astronaut
I spent 167 total days in outer space
152 of those living on board the
International Space Station in 2007 I
would do six spacewalks during my
30-year career with NASA at the Johnson
Space Center in Houston Texas
I'm ready to play never have I ever
never have I ever seen or witnessed
alien activity I have never witnessed
alien activity although my Russian
crewmates Allegan theater appeared
strange at times but I can't divulge any
information to you otherwise I'd be
violating government secrets never have
I ever pooped or peed in my spacesuit
I have peed in my spacesuit I've never
pooped there but I wore a mag NASA's
maximum absorbency garment otherwise
known to be laypeople as a diaper I was
in the midst of a seven hour and 41
minute spacewalk outside of the
International Space Station we don't get
to eat while we're out there but we do
get to drink water and as a result of
drinking water over seven hours and 41
minutes I close my eyes I concentrated
and I let her fly never have I ever
questioned whether we actually landed on
the moon I have never questioned the
fact that we landed on the moon for
those that disagree all I can say is I
have pity for you there's evidence still
there we can actually see it with
satellites we can see the remnants of
what the astronauts on Apollo 11 and
subsequent Apollo missions left there
with footprints if they left are still
there there's no atmosphere on the moon
so there's no wind to blow them away
there are a lot of photos available a
lot of cool stuff a lot of data out
there all you have to do is go to
nasa.gov and you'll learn everything you
need to know never have I ever looked at
the Earth from space and thought about
how small we are in the grand scheme of
things I have thought that every day 16
sunrises and sunsets every day as we
orbited the earth every 90 minutes I
would look out the windows when I had
time and I would see the beauty of God's
creation and you think about why the
earth is a spaceship and we're all
passengers on that spaceship and we're
sailing through outer space pretty cool
feeling pretty intimidating at times but
pretty proud that I had the opportunity
to do it never have I ever gotten drunk
in space I have never gotten drunk in
space however NASA says there is no
alcohol onboard the International Space
Station I'm not gonna provide you any
information here but if you read my book
the ordinary spaceman
you might learn about that exact topic
now we didn't get drunk in space but we
certainly enjoyed each other's company
Holland coat off and Fyodor yurchikhin
my two russian cosmonaut crewmates and I
dined every single meal together we
enjoyed that time we talked about family
we talked about friends we chastised
each other we laughed we discussed
technical issues but we had a lot of fun
never have I ever woken up and forgotten
I was in space I have done that during
my 152 days onboard the International
Space Station if I had a really good
night's sleep sometimes I'd wake up but
I wasn't quite sure where I was now some
people will tell you that their dreams
were weird in zero-gravity and that they
were crazy and strange and that they
dreamed they were falling or they were
hanging on for dear life I never had any
dreams like that my grants are all
pretty normal
they're doing about my wife I think
about my kids I dreamed about sports
activities I dreamed about my spacewalks
I slept really well and
I averaged 7 hours and 20 minutes of
sleep every night which is probably more
than I get on earth never have I ever
had sex in space like in the movies well
I have never had sex in space now there
are rumors to the effect that some have
or may have had sex in space but I have
no idea as to the origin of those rumors
or the truth or non truth behind those
rumors and we simply don't have any time
for that we're too busy working and
doing the right thing never have I ever
thought about staying in space and not
coming back to earth
I thought about whether or not I would
have to stay longer and you know when I
went back in 2010 for a 15-day mission
with a crew of discovery I really wanted
to stay longer 15 days back in my old
home was not long enough for me and I
could have stayed for a month or so I
don't think any of my crewmates wanted
to stay that long but they could have
left me for about a month longer and I
would have been happy I would had a
great time but after that I would have
been yearning to get back to earth again
never have I ever thrown up while I was
in space or on earth during a training
exercise I have thrown up on earth
during a training exercise it was my
first flight in a NASA t-38 jet I was
seated in the back seat I was gonna do
what they called the zoom and boom ride
and zoom and boom ride for me that day
turned into the world and hurl after
about an hour I fought like crazy I told
myself I was never gonna throw up but in
the end I puked in a trash can at
ellington Field and the t-38 hangar now
in space a lot of guys puke on the first
day a lot of people do but I was in the
mid-deck so I didn't have any
responsibility to fly the vehicle so I
took medication and I launched on June
the 8th of 2007 I did not puke until
November 7 2007 when
landed back at the Kennedy Space Center
in Florida and when I puked that day I
yak chunks it was pretty bad being an
astronaut was the dream of a lifetime I
had an opportunity to represent my
country and I still do I had an
opportunity to fly in space and see our
home planet from 250 miles up an
opportunity that very few people so far
in life have gotten to do I hope someday
that every single person on earth will
have the opportunity to fly in space
just like I did it will give us all a
different perspective on our lives and
it will give us a different perspective
on our planet Earth and what we can do
to preserve the wonderful opportunities
we have here on the blue planet
thanks a lot BuzzFeed appreciate you
having me on
[Music]